- Ultra-endurance sports didn't
just change me physically,
they actually gave me a brand new life.
Throughout my 30s, I was
climbing the corporate ladder,
very intent on achieving
the traditional idea
of the American dream.
But deep down inside,
I started to question
this path that I was on.
For well over a decade,
I really hadn't been
taking care of myself.
I had become a junk food addict,
I was 50 pounds overweight,
kind of semi-depressed,
and shortly before I turned 40,
I was climbing up a
simple flight of stairs
to go to bed one evening,
and I had to pause halfway.
I was winded, I was out of breath,
I had tightness in my chest,
and it was a very specific moment in time
in which I realized that not only that
I needed to change my lifestyle habits
but that I had the willingness
that I truly wanted to.
I realized that vague
ideas of eating better
or working out a little
bit or going to the gym
weren't really going to work for me.
I needed something specific,
something definitive.
I'd played around with a
bunch of different diets,
to no avail,
and I sort of attempted this
experiment in plant-based
eating as kind of the last
thing that I hadn't explored.
And I didn't have a big expectation
that it would make a big difference,
but within about seven to 10 days
of eating nothing but plants,
nothing with a mother,
nothing with a face,
I experienced this extraordinary thing,
like I had this resurgence in vitality,
my mental acuity improved,
my sleep improved,
I had this sense of well-being and energy
that I hadn't really felt
since I was a teenager.
And I didn't really know what I was doing,
but I knew in that moment
that I was onto something.
And it started getting me thinking
about human potential
and my own potential,
because if I could make
such a simple, basic shift
and experience such a dramatic result,
where were there other untapped reservoirs
of potential that I could explore?
And that's what got me
interested, ultimately,
in the world of ultra-endurance sports.
At the peak of training, I would say
I was training about 25 hours a week,
so it was really almost a second job,
and at the time, I was
still a practicing attorney,
I have four kids, I'm busy
doing a lot of things,
and in order to make the
time that was required
to appropriately prepare for this race,
I had to make some significant cuts
and really look hard and fast
at how I was spending my
time on a day-to-day basis.
I had to get rid of late-night television
and sort of business
meetings that could be
pushed to a conference
call or an email chain
to free up the time that was required
so I could show up at the
starting line and know
in my heart of hearts that
I could complete this race.
I started training,
which really connected me
with myself in a very profound way,
and to the surprise of
myself and many other people,
I ended up showing some
prowess in this field
and ended up competing
at a very high level,
specifically a race called Ultraman,
which is a double Ironman
distance triathlon.
Over the course of three days,
it completely circumnavigates
the entire big island of Hawaii.
(playful orchestral music)